après deux mois de fermeture le centre
équestre du perray-en-yvelines a rouvert
ses portes pour ses adhérents
la ministre des sports oksana
maracineanu est venu assister à un cours
d'équitation cours qui peut désormais se
dérouler en respectant les règles de
distanciation une réouverture
progressive et pourtant la structure qui
héberge 70 poneys et chevaux a malgré
tout continué de fonctionner pendant le
confinement
c'était une charge de travail sommes
importantes et les bancs les chevaux
continuer à manger
il fallait sortir tous les jours donc
c'était un petit peu un vrai challenge
d'arriver à avec un tout petit peu moins
non parce qu'il y avait malgré tout un
peu moins de on avait une ou deux
personnes en moins dans cette structure
le manque à gagner est estimé à 60%
il y a quelques semaines l'état a
débloqué 20 millions d'euros pour les
centres équestres et les parcs
zoologiques sur tout le territoire
on a besoin de nourrir et de sortir de
monter les chevaux donc cette aide a été
conséquente
et puis nous de manière générale le
gouvernement a apporté le chômage
partiel et nous y avons inclus au
ministère des sports tout l'écosystème
de la plus petite association jusqu'aux
clubs professionnels l'état souhaite
ainsi inciter les françaises et les
français à pratiquer de nouveau ce sport
le directeur du cpie reste optimiste
même s'il se pose plusieurs questions
sur l'avenir
est-ce que ça va être une priorité pour
les gens c'est sur les reprises et ce
qu'ils ont toujours un emploi est ce que
valent à ces questions si large quand on
peut pas dire youpi c'est la fête on
continue quand même faut rester vigilant
avant le confinement la filière équestre
était déjà en tension environ 10% de ce
type de structures pourraient faire
faillite en raison de la crise sanitaire